en 1992 jonathan shell publie le livre
le destin de la terre dans lequel il
écrit en gros ou bien nous nous
débarrassions des armes nucléaires ou
bien un no low cost va avoir lieu
presque quarante ans plus tard nous ne
sommes toujours pas débarrassé des armes
nucléaires et ses armes nucléaires n'ont
pas causé de l'holocauste la prédiction
de chali semble donc erroné moins que si
l'on prend la prédiction de shell
littéralement on peut remarquer que sa
prédiction ne fixe aucune limite de
temps ainsi que s'il ya un holocauste
nucléaire en 2003 164 ch elle aura eu
techniquement raison mais aura-t-il
moralement raison s la prédiction qu'il
avait en tête
et est-ce qu'il s'agit là de la chose
raisonnable à comprendre pour un lecteur
en 1982 lorsque le lecteur lisait la
prédiction de shell le même problème
s'est posé lorsque en novembre 2010 une
longue liste d'économistes avaient
cosigné une lettre demandant le retrait
des mesures de quantitative easing de
peur que ceux ci ne conduisent un risque
de dépréciation de la monnaie et
d'inflation
trois ans plus tard l'inflation n'a pas
eu lieu ce qui a amené barry holt a
qualifié la prédiction des économistes
de terriblement erronée mais là encore
on pouvait rétorqué la dépréciation et
l'inflation vont arriver plus
généralement le problème de telles
prédictions
c'est qu'elles ont une ambiguïté
fondamentale en ne précisant pas
l'échéance de la prédiction
or qui dit ambiguïté dit malléabilité
autrement dit toutes personnes de
mauvaise foi pour à réinterpréter la
prédiction pour prétendre qu'elle n'est
pas erroné si la personne veut défendre
la prédiction ou pour prétendre qu'elle
est erronée si la personne veut
critiquer la prédiction
or nous sommes tous de mauvaise foi
surtout quand il s'agit de défendre nos
déclarations publiques passées nous
sommes très souvent en mode auto
bullshit et bien souvent nous ne sommes
même pas conscients en 1988 philippe
clock auteur du livre super forecasting
a demandé à des experts de prédire la
probabilité que parti communiste
soviétique perdre le contrôle de l'urss
cinq ans plus tard après l'effondrement
de l'urss tête l'anc a demandé à ses
experts quelles étaient leurs
prédictions en 1988 et bien en moyenne
un mémoire des experts leur fit défaut
de 30% et surtout l'erreur de mémoire
n'avait absolument rien d'aléatoire
ainsi quand un expert avait prédit 10%
en 1988
en 1993 il se souvenait avoir prédit
quelque chose comme 40 ou 50 %
l'un des experts qui avaient prédit 20%
pensait même avoir prédit 70%
même en l'absence d'ambiguïté les
experts s'étaient auto bouchité pour se
donner davantage raison et ce
probablement sans même s'en rendre
compte
malheureusement en pratique les
prédictions surtout celles qui sont
télévisés sont remplies d'ambiguïté qui
permettent la malléabilité et qui
encouragent la mauvaise foi reprenons le
cas des économistes qu'est ce qui compte
comme une dépréciation de la monnaie et
une inflation
si le dollar se déprécie par rapport à
l'euro mais s'apprécie par rapport aux
iguanes devra tout dire que les
économistes ont vu juste et si
l'inflation est de 1% par an est ce
qu'on pourra dire que leurs prédictions
justes et qu'est ce que ces experts
entendait quand il parlait de risque
d'inflation
etait-ce d'une probabilité de 1% ou
parle et il d'une probabilité de 99%
malheureusement de telles ambiguïtés
laisse la porte grande ouverte à
l'automobile shit et à la mauvaise foi
pire de telles prédictions de nous dire
on en fait pas grand chose car elles
sont en fait bien trop vague pour être
vraiment prédictive et surtout il sera
dès lors impossible de juger de la
qualité des prédictions des experts pour
savoir dans quelle mesure qu'on peut
leur faire confiance
et pour mieux identifier les experts
qu'il faudrait davantage écoutés
malheureusement la manière dont les
prédictions sont reçus aujourd'hui à
tendance a gravement encourager l'auto
bullshit et la mauvaise foi
en effet pour les experts dont les
prédictions sont vagues banques allouent
complètement erroné y compris lorsqu'on
interprètent leurs propos avec
énormément de charité interprétative il
n'y a malheureusement pas de fin de
partie
au contraire de nombreux pseudos experts
répète des déclarations grandiloquentes
et des prédictions flou et il semble que
ce soit souvent précisément cela qui
leur permet d'être systématiquement
réinviter dans les médias et les
plateaux télé probablement parce que les
émissions avec de tels intervenants font
plus d'audience et parce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui dans une économie de
l'attention très concurrentiel
malheureusement l'écrasante majorité
d'entre nous donnons de la tension au
discours vagues grandiloquent ou
erronées y compris d'ailleurs lorsqu'il
s'agit de les critiquer ou de lait
moquer mais du coup nous valorisons au
moins financièrement l'invitation des
pseudo-experts par les médias en
particulier si ces experts veulent
persister à voir la tension qu'ils
recherchent le temps ces pseudos experts
ont tout intérêt à persévérer dans la
grandiloquence a ignoré le doter
l'incertitude et à effectuer des
prédictions dont prédictive à hisser le
jeu pas les joueurs et ça c'est très
gênant surtout quand il est en fait très
importante d'effectuer des prédictions
fiable pour prendre ensuite des
décisions bien informées comme par
exemple dans le cas du colis de 19 du
changement climatique des inégalités
sociales
si l'on veut accéder à de meilleures
prédictions il va lui falloir absolument
changer le jeu et ça c'est justement ce
qu'a fait le chercheur philippe tête loc
tout au long de sa carrière il a passé
sa carrière à concevoir des jeux de
prédiction qui ne laissait pas la place
là bas non pas cette fois pardon
peut-être loeb donc a passé sa carrière
à concevoir des jeux de prédiction qui
ne s'est pas la place à l'ambiguïté
on lui permettre de juger rigoureusement
la fiabilité des prédictions de
différents individus plus précisément
tête locke a proposé à de nombreuses
personnes d'assigner des probabilités à
différents événements futurs comme par
exemple la probabilité que le taux de
vaccination au 1er septembre prochain en
france dépasse 50%
je peux que les priorités je mettrais
tête lancôme ensuite noté la qualité des
prédictions à l'aide de notation
bayésienne pro honnêteté en particulier
d'utiliser la notation quadratique dont
on a parlé dans l'épisode 23
les résultats de ces recherches ont
ensuite été notamment compilé dans
l'excellent livre super forecasting que
je recommande très très très très
vivement
dans une première étude appelée experte
political jones tête l'homme découvrit
que les experts politiques étaient en
fait très mauvais en prédiction de façon
plus intéressante
son étude identifié à deux types
d'experts les premiers que ted l'anc
appelle des hérissons était aussi
mauvais que des chimpanzés qui
répondraient je ne sais pas de façon
systématique
autrement dit ces experts étaient aussi
mauvais que des ignares conscient de
l'étendue de leur ignorance
pire encore ces hérisson et est même
encore plus mauvais que des chimpanzés
quand il s'agissait de questions sur le
long terme l'autre type d'experts que
tel dans ce cas identifiés tête look les
a appelés des renards et se trouve que
les renards font mieux que les
chimpanzés
quoique pas très largement non plus en
fait de façon quelque peu embarrassante
même les renards et est du même niveau
que des algorithmes simpliste qui se
contentait de neupré dire aucun
changement de suivre la tendance
actuelle ce qui me fait dire que quand
on compare les humains aux algorithmes
on se fait sans doute très souvent une
image très idéalisée des humains tête il
découvrit par ailleurs que la différence
entre les renards et les hérissons
n'avait rien à voir avec leur idéologie
la différence avait à voir avec la
manière dont les experts réfléchissent
est en gros selon l'analyse de textes
locke ce qui s'appuyait systématiquement
sur des grands principes comme des
fondamentalistes du marché libre où des
gens qui pensent que l'état il a réponse
à tout ce genre de raisonnement était
caractéristique des hérissons ce qui
s'appuie systématiquement sur de tels
raisonnements faisait moins bien que des
chimpanzés voire pire selon cette loque
les renards eux sont plus pragmatiques
résonne plus au cas par cas avec les
outils parfois analytique et ont des
discours empli de mai et de cependant un
cycle de peut-être et de probablement
autrement dit la modestie épistémique
était corrélée avec de meilleures
prédictions tandis que l'abus de
discours grandiloquents était corrélée
avec de moins bonnes prédictions
néanmoins de façon peut-être étonnante
si le renard ont fait mieux que les
hérissons ce n'est pas parce qu'ils
répondent à systématiquement je ne sais
pas aux qcm bayésiens les renards
n'hésitez pas à y mettre parfois des
prédictions assez univoque et lorsqu il
le faisait il voyait alors plus juste
que les hérissons bref tout ça pour dire
que raisonner avec la modestie
épistémique approprié ce n'est
absolument pas dire systématiquement je
ne sais pas malheureusement tête locke
note que les hérissons sont sur
représentés dans les médias de façon
peut-être peu surprenante
la parole est trop souvent donnée à ceux
qui abusent de grands principes ce zoo
pro
mon analyse toute l'actualité sous un
angle de vue refuse les concessions
rejette l'incertitude et émettent des
prédictions vagues et non prédictive
quelques années après avoir prédit de
façon univoque mais à tort que l'irak de
saddam hussein possédait des armes de
destruction massive
les services de renseignement américains
ont enfin décidé de questionner leurs
propres capacités de prédiction et pour
y arriver ils ont financé un comité de
scientifiques chargés d'étudier l'art de
la prédiction ce comité monte à une
étude exceptionnel appelé le good job du
monde project ce projet a recruté des
milliers de volontaires à travers le
pays il est soumis à des défis de
prédiction probabiliste sur le futur
mais surtout ce projet explorera des
solutions pour obtenir les meilleures
prédictions possible en s'appuyant sur
des qcm bayésiens sur des événements
futurs
bien définies de façon stupéfiante la
crainte que pouvaient légitimement avoir
des services de renseignement fut
confirmé un ensemble de volontaires
motivés une agrégation simpliste de
leurs jugements sont capables de
systématiquement battre les services de
renseignement nationaux en terme de
prédiction géopolitique
quand bien même ces volontaires n'avait
pas accès aux informations
confidentielles
ils n'étaient pas grassement payés pour
effectuer ces prédictions en particulier
l'étude permis d'identifier une
cinquantaine d'individus
particulièrement brillant dans cette
tâche de prédiction des individus que
ted locke appelle désormais des supers
forecaster qu'on pourrait traduire par
super prédicteurs ces champions de la
prédiction avait des scores 60% meilleur
que les autres selon la notation
quadratique et de façon stupéfiante
il voyait plus juste pour des
prédictions à l'échelle de l'année que
les autres pouvaient le faire à
l'échelle de quatre mois mieux encore
année après année au lieu de subir une
régulation à la moyenne c'est super
forecaster s'améliorait et creuser
l'écart qui les séparait des autres de
façon peut être surprenante parmi les
champions de la prédiction on trouve des
profils divers et variés lionel levin
est un mathématiciens et statisticiens
sont 10 in man est un ancien chercheur
en sciences de l'atmosphère
jay felder est un chercheur en sciences
politiques devant pierre bourgault une
thèse en histoire
marie simpson à une thèse en économie
est maintenant consultant en finance de
gorge et david aux drogues sous des
anciens développeurs informatiques bel
flac est un ancien employé du
département de l'agriculture américain
dans la rue
on a des vignes de filles est un ancien
ouvrier à l'usiné est désormais
assistant social dans un gouvernement
d'état al kilkenny est une femme au
foyer qui même si elle ne fait pas
partie encore des supers forecaster n'en
est pas loin
en particulier les 40 meilleurs que la
quasi totalité d'entre nous enfin hélène
brik dont la photo est dans la vignette
de cette vidéo est pharmacienne c'est
super forecaster ont toutefois de
nombreux traits en commun ils sont tous
à l'aise avec les chiffres
ils ont une envie profonde de
constamment progresser ils critiquent
constamment leurs prédictions il
décompose systématiquement les problèmes
en dessous question il effectue
régulièrement des petits pas de danse
pour ajuster leur crédence et ils
reconnaissent volontiers le rôle de la
chance c'est super forecaster sont en
fait surtout des champions dubase à nice
mme pragmatique
pour effectuer une bonne prédiction que
ce soit avec nos cerveaux de primates ou
si on veut les utiliser des machines
trois ingrédients semblent à la fois
nécessaire et suffisant en premier lieu
il faut bien sûr des données ou si vous
voulez l'appeler différemment de
l'information il faut ensuite un
hardware pour analyser ces données comme
le cerveau humain ou une machine et
enfin il faut une épistémologie c'est à
dire une méthode pour analyser ces
données et pour ensuite émettre une
prédiction
et bien sûr il faut que chacun de ses
composants fonctionnent très bien
idéalement il faudrait énormément de
données de très grande qualité
il faudrait un cerveau extrêmement
efficace une machine surpuissante pour
gérer une grande quantité d'informations
potentiellement divergentes et il
faudrait une excellente façon de
raisonner typiquement très proche de la
formule de bayes si l'on en croit cette
série ou si on en croit le livre de tête
loc
ok mais si l'on devait seulement choisir
un parmi les 3 quel est selon vous celui
que vous devriez améliorer quel est
selon vous le goulot d'étranglement
quelle est la chose qui s'ils ont passé
un jour ou un an à l'améliorer nous
permettrait d'effectuer de bien
meilleures prédictions
et bien selon le livre de tête locke
dans le cas des humains les données le
hardware ne sont pas les plus déficient
en effet certains super forecaster ont
des cuirs raisonnable et ont un accès
uniquement à internet mais de façon
stupéfiante ceci ne les empêche pas de
faire mieux que des analystes de la cia
au qi surhumains et ayant accès à des
informations confidentielles selon
l'analyse de tête locke le goulot
d'étranglement
le truc le plus important à améliorer
c'est très nettement la méthode on
utilise pour effectuer des prédictions
en particulier comment décide-t-on
t'attaquer un problème de prédiction
comment décortique ton le problème
comment cherchons ensuite les
informations pertinentes
quelles informations vaut-il mieux
ignorer et lesquels méritent notre
attention comme ensuite utiliser ces
informations pour affiner nos crédence
comment combiner différentes certitude
comment ensuite critiquer nos
prédictions et surtout comment améliorer
les algorithmes qu'on utilise pour
effectuer nos prédictions qu'elle et
l'épistémologie qu'on utilise lorsqu'il
s'agit de faire des prédictions selon
cette loque
telles sont les questions qui distingue
les forecaster des supers forecaster et
à en croire l'analyse de tête locle et
super forecaster la distinction résident
ray beaucoup dans la capacité et la
volonté des prédicteurs à effectuer des
approximations efficace et à ses fidèles
des lois des probabilités et donc j'ai
envie de dire que voir et revoir cette
série sur le bail à nice mme n'est
peut-être pas complètement inutile